Sam listen to me
America reconstruction ISM her dream
isn't dead
I don't want here this is the face of
our new hope our new America
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my mother may be gone but I'm here and
you Sam you're here too
been 10 years since you saw each other
right and in all that time she hasn't
aged a day
he knows why my body's still on the
beach I don't get to grow older but you
do Sam you look good so you're serious
then about reconnecting everyone and
everything
someone has to succeed Bridget Sam more
importantly someone has to carry on her
legacy and see our country rebuilt
samantha america strand our new
president a new beginning for our people
for our nation under Emily's leadership
will re-establish the UCA
the united cities of america this is how
we'll rebuild our country but we'll need
your help to do it Sam through with this
I said my goodbyes to all of you and I
said him to Bridget we never forgot
about you Sam you ran away you cut us
off Emily put together an expedition the
best of bridges won and went west
past craters and bt territory I kept
them safe while they searched for
survivors
never once missed a BT so I'm coming a
mile away
we convinced community after community
to join the UCA and we left behind our
own people to help them it took us three
years but we managed to make it all the
way to edge not City all the way to the
Pacific Jesus yeah but then everything
went to hell
the team was wiped out and Emily was
taken
taken I'm not being kept in a Cell or
anything like that I'm allowed to use
their facilities and to speak with you
whenever I want I just can't leave the
city it's all to safeguard the continued
independence of edge not City but that's
what our keepers are saying at least
they want the UCA to leaving be Emily's
their insurance policy in case we don't
who are these [ __ ] again homo demons
militant separatist group they run edge
not City I've heard of them
bunch of terrorists who go around towns
killing people from leaving craters
right nothing's off-limits for them not
even engineering boy doubts you think
the suicide that took out central not
was one of theirs could be they're
extremists like the demons everywhere
plotting in the shadows they're
decentralized by nature no one
organization to rule them all
just a common ideology I know not
everyone shares our vision for the
future if we Americans don't come
together again humanity won't survive
I carried my mother's message to people
all across the country but not everyone
who was willing to accept it more than a
few would rather stay isolated keep to
themselves go it alone
[Music]
like you Sam they think that America can
only be rebuilt by force by men who tell
them what to do who take away their
freedom and put them in shackles would
you put on me huh you know better than
the demons just another kind of cult
they're not shackles Sam they're a
symbol of our bonds that's what we need
right now not to stand apart but to come
together to form chiral knots and
reconnect Sam we want you to go west and
finish what Emily started the people she
left behind have been hard at work
setting up Cairo Network terminals but
these terminals are still isolated we
need you to bring them online and for
that you'll need a cupid this contains
all the necessary security and
operations protocols to integrate a
terminal into the Cairo web take the
Cupid West to Sam and reconnect the
people of our great nation and when you
get to edge not City bye Emily and bring
her home
after that I'll take over the presidency
and carry on mother's work to save the
country
this was bridges dying wish this is how
we'll move forward please Sam we need
you and Sam Porter bridges now I'm not a
strand hell I'm not even part of this
outfit
you all saw to that I'm not getting
involved with you or anyone else ever
again wait
[Music]
see it's like I'm not even here
same as it ever was
please